if you're celebrating this holiday
season you may also find yourself
hovering over a bowl of eggnog or
avoiding one depending on your taste the
creamy concoction has long stirred
debate over its place on the holiday
cocktail menu
and in recent years eggnog has found
competition from other drinks like
coquito a rum-based coconut drink with
puerto rican roots i like the sound of
it our dish for our series the dish vlad
duties looks at why despite the
polarizing reputation of egla eggnog and
its cousins it has stood the test of
time
true to its name
authentic eggnog starts with you guessed
it eggs so we're gonna whip that up but
as we learned during a recent visit to
stockade tavern in kingston new york
there's so much more to it we're using
cognac
regular heavy cream owners paul maloney
and his wife jenny have been serving
eggnog to their customers for the last
12 years maloney uses a recipe dubbed
the baltimore eggnog which dates back to
the 1800s and here in kingston the first
capital of new york state it's likely
some of the earliest settlers were
drinking an even older version the
colonials drank a ton of eggnog new
england was a major rum exporter and
maker pirate juice they call it right
and so it needed to be tamed with a
little bit of cream some sugar some eggs
why is there such a love-hate
relationship with eggnog for me it's a
pure love relationship and uh but i
unders i understand that it's very bad
for you it's no worse for you than
sucking on the tailpipe of a crosstown
bus
at the dead rabbit in new york city we
met up with cocktail historian dave
wondrich who just completed a nearly
900-page guide he let us sample his
homemade eggnog cheers cheers
it's pretty good it's pretty good who is
the person who said you know what
would be really great
eggs
and cream
and booze
i mean some form it goes back to
antiquity or certainly the middle ages
it does it wasn't always a seasonal
drink people did drink it
year round but new year's day was a big
deal the women of the house would stay
home with a huge bowl of punch or eggnog
or both and the men would go to all
their friends houses and have a drink by
the end of the 19th century it's really
just a special occasion thing it has a
flavor
that gives you
comfort yeah when you order a martini i
don't get comfort from this well see
that might be where we differ
does it now become a drink for the new
world i mean are they still drinking it
or any other place there's a coquito in
puerto rico where they use
coconut milk
coquito means little coconut a nod to
its main ingredient the caribbean
holiday treat has grown in popularity
over the last few years we have rum and
then we always have coconuts on a recent
visit to puerto rico we stopped in
factoria bar and met bartender roberto
bercia who makes a recipe passed down by
his grandmother a pinch of ginger it
gives you a little bit of taste but also
a texture when you first put ginger
into your coquito where did that come
from my grandmother used to give you hot
milk with ginger honey you make memories
from the experiences and then also you
remind memories from your palate this is
your glass wow yeah okay
not unlike what maloney hopes to achieve
all the way in kingston what was last
year like with the pandemic raging i
wasn't giving out much eggnog which was
sad people would come still to our
window where we were selling drinks out
the window and it was touching how does
it make you feel when someone who's
not been a fan of eggnog and says you
know what i'm converted that's it feels
great it happens all the time well
awesome people like that's not for me
but you can give my date some and
i go i'll go back and be like you know
they had a sip
now we're going to put some nutmeg i've
never actually seen a real live no meg
kidding happy holidays happy holidays
cheers thank you wait wait so why does
vlad get all the food and drink stories
what's going on you guys said you're
going to help me out on that yeah i love
me some eggnog matter of fact tony look
in your cup i got some eggnog for you
yeah i might raise my glass to pour it
out not for me i like the non-alcoholic
kind but i haven't seen it that thick
and um curdly before so i'm very curious
about that type of consistency yeah yeah
we're big fans of eggnog i like the idea
of the coquito over the eggnog i also
like the idea of being a cocktail
historian i always thought a cocktail
historian with someone who remembers the
night before but apparently it's you got
to know the whole history that sounds
like a really not just what happened oh
well then i'm historian then
we're all historians you can get an
eggnog at the grocery store do you guys
buy borden's eggnog right there in the
grocery store very good is that the good
one that's a good one there today i
highly recommend it